welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz and this is another
15 minutes with a mentor episode and
basically in this series we're gonna ask
mentors from inside the community seven
questions
in 15 minutes i'm really excited to be
joined by
mark thomas and before i ask you the
first question mark why don't you
introduce yourself for those that may
not know who you are
and we'll get into it cool yeah cheers
pleasure to be here um so yeah i'm mark
thomas
i work for eames consulting which are uh
financial services insurance
predominantly specialist recruitment
brand based in
london uh hong kong singapore um
and i'm the technology and change
business with uh with a colleague of
mine
um in predominantly a business
development and
sales focus kind of leadership role
amazing
so first question what was
your biggest challenge in 2020 how did
you overcome it and what did you learn
from it
um so it'd be very easy to say covered
which obviously was everyone's biggest
challenge but
um i think for me so so a bit of content
so before i joined
eames i worked at like a technology
recruiting business for 10 years and
and ended up running that for a couple
years and then ended up moving on from
there
just just over two years ago so 20
sorry 2019 january so and i joined eames
in order to to run technology for them
but also
to uh start up a regional office so i i
don't live in london i live in uh like a
small village
out towards swindon way um and so we
planned to set up an office in reading
which we did so we we set that up in
the start 2019 to two years ago um
and and over the whole of 2019 i built
that that office
up um to the point we had i think seven
eight people
everything was going really well we had
a really like nice device
plan for for the next few years um
started 2020 with a bang everything was
going really well and then obviously
covered hit and everyone was working
from home um most of the people i had
working for me had only been working for
me for
six to twelve months some some literally
a couple of
like a month or so something i think a
couple three or four of them and started
in january that that year so they've
literally been with me for no time
and suddenly we're all working from home
um so really the hardest thing was i
mean ultimately went through a process
to the point where
we me and the leadership team at eames
thought about
what we actually needed and given that
we were going to be working from home
in the future state um probably
i mean half the time at least did we
need a regional office so
ultimately that meant that very quickly
we needed to let some people go
to two people had only been with me for
a matter of weeks so so we
we let them go because they were just
going to be a cost and um
so that was tough like having to let
people go quit quit a job to come and
work for you you told him during
and you have to let them go because not
because they're not they're not good but
because they're they're just
they just don't have uh they're not
going to make any money they're just
going to
suck money out of the resources for for
a couple of months and then and then not
laterally to make the decision to
actually close the reading office
um so yeah pretty tough in like of all
the things i've done recruitment
letting people that we didn't actually
let any of those people go we
we actually gave them the opportunity to
work in london and be based from homes
part-time but naturally some of those
people didn't want to travel to london
et cetera et cetera so i mean look what
what did i learn from it is
no matter how good your plan is
something like kobe can come along and
and completely ruin it all right so i
think the most important thing is
yeah it's great to have a plan and great
to have a long-term plan but you've got
to be agile enough to be able to pivot
and change
change and adapt and adapt quickly and
the one thing i can say eames did
brilliantly
is they uh as a business we made
decisions really quickly and some people
thought they were a bit
uh hasty but but actually i think we
we made good decisions really quickly
and it made it made actually
us in a pretty good state now we've made
a profit every month since so it's it's
it's been okay um i won't say it wasn't
tough
thank you for sharing that um so next
one interested
to hear this from you so what working
from home tip could you share with other
recruiters listen to this that
has had a massive impact on your own
productivity
yeah so uh working from home like i
wasn't at work from my own person at all
before this i probably count on one hand
how many days i've worked from home in
12 13 years i just i
i i hated it i've kind of grown to to
quite enjoy it um i think the most
important thing about working from home
for me
is is having structure like having a
having a plan like i always get up
shower get ready for work as though i
was as i was going to work in the office
and and spend time sat like in the
office have lunch breaks um
i've just kind of got my by my wife
pestering me
is have managed to like start going for
a walk every lunch time it means i've
got some structure to my day
a bit like what i would have if i was in
london i would go out at lunchtime go
for a walk get some lunch or something
like that
um so for me that's the most important
part like that's
been the change for me now i've got a
structure and structure very similarly
to i am in work
it makes it a bit easier i think if you
don't have that you can easily just
become a bit demotivated and just not
not focus on what you what you need to
do and activities you need to do each
day and stuff like that
yeah absolutely i definitely agree with
you on that and i know there will be
different sort of channels that you use
but from
your own experience what's been the most
effective way
for you to win business in the last 12
months would you say
um so i i kind of break the mould a
little bit so i i am i am i am
i'm certainly not against cold calling
and and
being on the phone but i also think that
there i think
recruitment people recruitment get a
little bit too bogged down on that
there's multiple ways of winning clients
and some people are great at sending
brilliant
emails and winning clients that way and
getting people on the phone that way
i've been quite good at that in the past
but you mean
in the last 12 months the most important
thing that's coming to home to roost for
me is the fact that
i spent 13 years building relationships
with people
and actually those relationships really
come to come to the the forefront when
when when times are tough so you can
pick up the phone and speak to people
and there's there's a lot of recruiters
and i've seen a lot of them that
have quite a few some have worked for me
that that have a very short time
term mindset so they they only really
want they and and that's
partly driven by the way our industry is
like everyone's looking for the next fee
um and so therefore if someone a senior
person who's not relevant for a role
that you're working you don't speak to
them because they're not going to
provide you with
cash in the bank right then but actually
you've kind of got to think of the
long-term compound effect of speaking to
that many people do you mean so
my attitude has always been speak to as
many people as possible they may not pay
pay uh give you an invoice or pay any
money to you right now but but
longer term people remember those those
those kind of relationships and those
not that long-term
mindset so for me that that in the last
12 months that's 100
been been what's what's paid dividends
to me people who i've worked with before
who remember who have done
good work for you can go back and
revisit not always the same
necessarily if you're new into the job
but start it's always a good time to
start right
yeah no i really like that so
interested to hear this from you what
what habit or hobby
did you start in 2020 that you're going
to continue in 2021
uh so so i probably just answered it
it's it's walking like
if you if you ask anyone that knows me i
i just i don't walk anywhere like
i get there i spend i'm apart from
around the golf course
um so my missus would have asked
me about a hundred times to go for a
walk at lunchtime and stuff like that
and i just i just didn't do it i hated
it i hated
it um but i found that in knockdown one
of the things i was doing when i didn't
have structures i was getting to the end
of like a thursday and i've not been at
the house for like four
days or something like that so um so
because i'm working from home i just
like my commute was about
five yards from them from the bedroom to
the to the office so
um so that's the one thing i've started
doing and i've got kind of quite into
counting
how many steps i do and and making sure
i do like regular activity and stuff
like that so
so yeah i probably begrudgingly i'll
i'll probably carry on doing it in
fairness
quite quite enjoyed it getting a bit
fresh love that
so which do you think is better the
first coffee in the morning or the first
pint
post work on a friday i don't drink
coffee so it's
very easy
so yeah i don't drink coffee i'm not
really allowed in definitely agree with
me caffeine so um
so yeah that and i bought it even if it
was even if i did drink coffee it would
definitely be the point
yeah right so the next next one is it's
slightly different it's
it's more of a scenario and i want for
sort to hear how you how you'd approach
it so
a particular business that you've that
you've had on your
target target client list for over a
year or a long period of time
you've had a couple of touch points with
different people different hiring
managers
over that time at this business from i
don't know some of them might have
engaged some of your content on linkedin
you might send a couple of emails but
through your candidate network you
managed to get
one of their their contact numbers on
the hiring managers and you call that
person
they pick up the answer they say hello
who is this and
i want to hear sort of what you'd say or
or how you'd approach it
right okay so um so i've never spoke to
this person before
no but they may have seen your name like
that you
they may have engaged with some of your
content or like you may have ended up in
their inbox at some point like there's
definitely been touch points for sure
yeah so for me like it's funny i was
talking to this about
for our uh our head of training this
morning but um
for me what i would do and what i've
always done in this is is try to build
some kind of rapport
like and there's and actually a lot of
people talk about how you do this and
i've had consultants ask me before and
it's really hard to teach but and
actually the the thing people
mistake uh get wrong is is that they
uh they tried to tell them what things
to build rapport on and
that's that's not the right thing to do
it's what's most important for me is to
understand what you're interested in
and and make that something that someone
else could be interested in as well find
common ground
so obviously i would intro with what i
was doing i i certainly wouldn't go into
some big long spiel about what eems do
and stuff like that because
frankly i just don't think people really
care about that like
they ultimately really wonder why
they're talking to you who you are
and and if you are going to talk to what
value they've got spending this time to
speak to you
so um if they're aware of me it makes it
a bit easier because you you therefore
can
you hopefully have got some kind of
banked rapport already because they know
you a bit
but i i always tried to find some common
ground so that i i think i just
mentioned before
i've got a nine-month-old baby which is
a pretty good way to build build some
kind of rapport so when if someone else
has got a kid
they know what it's like to have a nine
month old baby but it's not easy
so especially if it's your first one so
i think for me
are you seeing that i play a lot of golf
i use golf a lot as
a way to people to talk about blokes who
play golf love talking about golf
and sport in general um and and just
tried to find common ground i mean
obviously even like i mean you can use
coronavirus and how i think i said to
you like
how's uh i was locked down treating you
and that before we went on that's it's a
pretty good way of building some rapport
so that would always be my in that would
always be my
my starting point to try and break down
some barriers and
i think then laterally i then try and
try and turn that into a
as much of a two-way conversation as
possible so
i don't really see client calls and
candidate courses separate i think
that's another mistake recruiters made
every candidate and every client is
potentially the opposite
so i i and it's amazing how many times i
i've got clients off the
back of speaking to people who have
thought they were a candidate so
i would i would actually enter the
conversation and just try to find out
where they're at
at the moment so are they hiring do do
they do what what are their problems at
the moment and that might be that
they're looking for a job if so it might
mean that the first call that i have
with them
i end up talking to them about what
they're looking for and
and what job they they might be
interested in i don't actually even get
to the point where i even make a sale
um because actually sometimes you're
better off leaving that so
um so it'd be a load of fact finding and
then at that point you
you need to make a call and again the
biggest mistake i think people make is
that
they go for the close too soon like they
they they have a really good call with
someone and they turn it into an awkward
call by trying to close them when
actually
you're better off leaving them with a
great experience they've just met a guy
who plays golf he's got kids that they
really enjoy speaking to
and actually who might help them find a
job and actually just leave it as that
and revisit it again next week
yeah yeah no that that's yeah really you
went on some interesting things there so
thank you
so last question so
so final question really is basically i
want you to sort of imagine that
i'm a recruiter who's i've set my goals
for 2021 i'm hoping to
have a more successful 2021 and i've
written down my goals i'm feeling
motivated
and i guess what i sort of just want to
i'd be interested to hear from you is
like what would your advice be to me
that you think would give me the best
possible chance of actually achieving
my goals so
i think so i think for me it's it's it's
about breaking them down
so like lots of people at the start of
the year focus on this really big kind
of goal that they've got for
for for 2021 or whatever the year would
be and it's it's
it's kind of it's good to have but it's
kind of unachievable so
it goes back to a little bit like i i
like to structure
i i have kind of daily activities that i
absolutely must do no matter what what
happens and i structure them into my day
so
for example i always always without sale
without fails and send five business
development emails every single day
and then normally be identified from
um from leads i've got the previous day
or people i've looked at
that's just one example but i think what
you need to come up whatever that big
goal is work backwards and figure out
what you need to do
weekly monthly and then factor it into
that and focus on the week
focus on on having a 100 achievable week
because if you focus too much on the
goal you'll either lose track of it
you'll become unrealistic very quickly
or or you'll back load it and really not
worry about it till you get to the end
of the year and then it's too late
so i think you need to break it down i
would i would suggest weekly and daily
is that
is the way to do it um and and have that
all those
numbers figure out feed into the thing
it's a bit of an old school recruitment
method right work work backwards if you
need to do
figure out how many sales calls you need
to do to get x number and work work
backwards and that but it works
it works for me 100 if i don't have a
day plan and a structure know what good
looks like for a day or a week
then you've got no chance of of of
achieving the
the annual one because it's just too
much of a bigger target
yeah great mark that was it
50 minutes with a mentor now dude thank
you so much